despite what you hear from the media and
the left the president and the
Republican Party are winning on the
issue of immigration a majority of
Americans support tighter border
enforcement are against by the way even
increases in legal immigration and
support defunding sanctuary cities now
check this out even in California a new
UC berkley poll finds that 59 percent of
Californians say it is very or somewhat
important to increase deportations of
illegals music to my ears a full forty
nine percent support temporarily banning
people from majority Muslim countries
from entering the United States
do you realize that goes even further
than president Trump's travel ban from
just six majority Muslim countries
did I mention that's California
determined to fulfill his campaign
promises and focus on Americans first
the president urged Congress on Capitol
Hill today as he has since taking office
to tighten restrictions on illegal
immigration we are calling on Congress
to secure our borders support our border
agents stop sanctuary cities and shut
down policies that release violent
criminals back into our communities we
don't want it any longer
we've had it American people have had it
it's about time we end the old twisted
approach of catch and release at the
border now for all you common sense
voters out there this get-tough approach
makes perfect sense the grassroots I
think the majority the Republican Party
is more unified than ever
behind this agenda of the president so
leave it to a small liberal band of
Republicans to try to splinter the party
just before the midterm elections this
is beautiful and by the way over daca of
all things it turns out that at least 18
Republicans you see the rogues gallery
there
have signed something called a discharge
petition it would essentially give the
Democrats and a few liberal Republicans
run of the House floor and the ability
to bring several immigration bills to a
vote including a bill granting amnesty
to the daca kids now normally a
discharge petition is launched by the
opposition party
it requires 218 signatures to engage so
in this case 25 Republicans and all the
Democrats would need to be in favor to
support it so CNN is reporting tonight
by the way that they already have the
numbers to do the discharge position
petition but the lawmakers could provide
no evidence to that fact
now the peculiar thing here is that the
discharge petition again was launched by
Republicans as a challenge to GOP
leadership and of course to the
president Florida Republican Carlos
Cabello in Jeff Denham of California
notorious open borders Republicans were
the prime movers but the petition has
been signed by others as well including
unbelievably Utah's Mia love will heard
of Texas
mario diaz Villard and Ileana
ros-lehtinen of Florida Charlie dent of
Pennsylvania whose vote still counts
even though he's already resigned fred
Upton of Michigan David Reichert of
Washington Colorado's Mike Kaufman Chris
Collins Elise Stefanik of New York and
mark Amodei of Nevada New York's John
Catco is also considering signing these
representatives should be ashamed of
themselves at this point I mean come on
by defying their leadership and the
White House what do they do they
demoralize the base of the GOP and they
weaken unity before the midterm
elections so rather than keeping a focus
on the economy that is booming these
Republicans have decided it's in their
political interest to turn the spotlight
to immigration and the daca kids who
cares if it means handing over party
power to the opposition to do it on
Thursday speaker Ryan reacted to this
discharge petition uprising during a
press conference
and we never want to turn the floor over
to the minority and what I don't want to
do is have a process that just ends up
with a veto we actually want to solve
the daka problem going down a path and
having some kind of a spectacle on the
floor that just results in a veto
doesn't solve a problem and that is why
I think it's important for us to come up
with a solution that the president can
support well the president already
offered something and the Democrats said
no to it last February come on we all
knows wasting time it's not up to a
minority of Republicans who view whose
views by the way did not prevail in the
2016 election cycle - now at this point
try to reset the national debate on daca
it's absurd if they want to do something
to actually help America what they
should do is urge some more moderate
Democrats to help reform let's say the
asylum process that is being abused
today by illegals do you know that
asylum applications have increased by
seventeen hundred percent over an
eight-year period alone huh I wonder why
that's happening at a moment when the
Real Clear Politics average now has the
generic ballot tightening from a
previous 13-point advantage for
Democrats to basically within the margin
of error basically a dead heat now this
is not the moment to distract voters
from their number one priority the
economy to allow this discharge daca
petition to proceed could be a midterm
turnout killer and it will splinter the
party focus on the things that are
working and the things that will win you
the majority in November keep the
majority jobs wages safety and yes
pocketbook issues so if you're upset
like I am about what these liberal
Republicans are trying to push call your
Congressman
call your congresswoman tell them how
you feel about this this parliamentary
stunt will not go down well with the GOP
base I can tell you that right now my
radio lines were ringing off the hook
today you would think by the way that
Republicans just did back up for a
moment would learn their lesson at this
point after that
stris 20 2007 excuse me Bush McCain
amnesty that went down in flames a lot
of us on talk radio were up in arms
about that and led the revolt against
that and after the disastrous 2013
Schumer Rubio gang of eight fiasco that
amnesty behemoth was so bad even Rubio
himself disowns it now Lisi learned his
lesson Republicans as the party in power
have a real chance to break the midterm
election curse not lose many seats maybe
not lose any maybe even pick up a few
seats but only if the amnesty fanatics
are defeated once again and that's the
angle